[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers guten
Abend ihnen es ist der Tag danach für
Russland und die Welt rätselt immer noch
und mehr denn je was das genau war
gestern ein Putschversuch eine
Machtdemonstration gar eine Inszenierung
klar ist nur eins nach diesem Tag mit
russischen Panzern auf dem Weg gehen
Moskau mit einer Privatarmee die
russische militärzentralen besetzt mit
einem Söldner Chef der das
verteidigungset Establishment und dessen
Begründung für den Ukraine Krieg
bloßstellt nach diesem Tag ist nichts
mehr so wie zuvor im reicht es Vladimir
Putin auch wenn es rein äußerlich so
aussehen mag der Kremlherrscher ist
angeschlagener denn je sein System
labiler als gedacht Sebastian berichtet
am Tag danach dominiert der Aufstand der
Wagner seltener die russischen
Nachrichten doch Putin geschwächt ist
diese Frage wird gar nicht erst gestellt
die Botschaft des gleichgeschalteten
Staatsfernsehens das Volk steht
geschlossen hinter seinem Präsidenten
Unterstützung der normalen Bevölkerung
die Sie gerade in den Beitrag gesehen
haben und wegen der Konsolidierung aller
Machtbereiche wurde die Krise gelöst
doch es zeigen sich Risse im
normalerweise perfekt orchestrierten
Bild das Putin von sich in den Medien
sehen will der sonst laute und
aggressive Kreml Propagandist Wladimir
sollwiw ist geschockt und feiert dann
nicht Putin als Held sondern den bierla
russischen Präsidenten Lukaschenko der
bislang vom Kreml abhängig war
wir haben Lukaschenko schon einmal
geholfen doch jetzt hat Alexander
Lukaschenko zweifellos den Titel Held
Russlands verdient weil es ihm gelungen
ist das Wichtigste zu tun Blutvergießen
zu verhindern
eigentlich keine anderen Helden neben
sich der russische Präsident verspricht
seinen Bürgern Sicherheit und inszeniert
sich seit über 20 Jahren als Machthaber
der Stärke und Kontrolle
gestern sah es stundenlang so aus als
habe Putin die Kontrolle über sein Reich
verloren bis pregorjin schließlich abzog
tatsächlich eine Demütigung von
Präsident Putin der in seiner Ansprache
Animation die Rebellen als Verräter
bezeichnete
zu verhandeln und ihnen Sicherheit zu
garantieren
Vladimir Putin hat einer schwer
bewaffneten Privatarmee nachgegeben
einen seiner Herrschaft einmaliger
Vorgang es werden Gerüchte laut
pregorian habe möglicherweise Verbündete
im Moskauer Machtapparat
normalerweise gibt Putin öffentlichem
Druck niemals nach gestern war dazu
gezwungen und das ist ein Zeichen dafür
dass nicht alles gut ist und sich das
macht Gleichgewicht in der russischen
Regierung verändert
sich gestern beim Abzug von seinen Fans
feiern und schafft Bilder die Putin
schon lange nicht mehr produziert hat
fest steht rigorin hat mit seinem Marsch
auf Moskau dem System Putin einen herben
Schlag versetzt
ja die Schockwellen werden sich weiter
ausbreiten manche sagen wir sind im
fünften Akt von Putins Macbeth artiger
Präsidentschaft Rüdiger von Fritz war
bis 2019 deutscher Botschafter in Moskau
er kennt das Land seine Machtstrukturen
und Vladimir Putin guten Abend
es gibt Stimmen heute die sagen das
könnte alles auch ein gigantisches
Schauspiel gewesen sein eine Show
inszeniert gar von Putin persönlich
können Sie dem was abgewinnen
und sehr wenig muss ich sagen denn zum
einen gelingt es bekanntermaßen jedem
sehr schlecht raffiniert ausgedacht der
Pläne auch erfolgreich umzusetzen und
zum anderen muss man ja nur auf das
Ergebnis schauen Vladimir Putin ist
schwer angeschlagen er ist angezählt
nicht nur vor der Weltöffentlichkeit
sondern auch vor seinem eigenen Volk
jeder in Russland weiß was los ist dass
er nicht Jena starke unumstrittene
Führer ist der immer vorgegeben hat zu
sein und wenn man in der russischen
Politik eines nicht zeigen darf dann ist
es Schwäche was passiert jetzt mit dem
Söldner Chef mit bregorien der geht laut
Deal mit dem Kreml nach Belarus aber er
geht doch dort nicht aufs alten Teil
oder
schwer vorstellbar dass ähm
jede Funktion verliert er war ja bisher
schon extrem nützlich und wir dürfen
nicht vergessen dass er sehr viel mehr
getan hatte als eine besonders brutale
Art der Kriegsführung in der Ukraine
voranzutreiben er ist der für Russland
nützlicherweise vielfach in anderen
Ländern im Einsatz und so steht sehr
stark zu vermuten Hinweise deuten darauf
an beispielsweise selbst im Schleuser
Milieu in Nordafrika um auf diesem Wege
zu versuchen im Sinne der russischen
Führung Europa zu der stabilisieren dann
gucken wir doch jetzt mal bitte auf das
ganz große Bild wir hatten gestern in
der Sendung hier ein militär-experten
der sagt wir sollten in Deutschland
keine Angst davor haben was passiert
wenn Putin stürzen sollte das wie groß
ist die Chance aber wie groß eben auch
die Gefahr
einstweilen denke ich sollten wir davon
ausgehen dass Wladimir Putin zunächst in
der Macht bleibt und seine Linie
unverdrossen fortsetzt nämlich jene
massive Repression im Innern und großer
Aggression im äußeren zum anderen muss
man aber sehen dass sich jene doch
ermutigt fühlen die immer schon in einem
sehr typischen russischen doppeldenken
scheinbar Loyalität demonstriert haben
auch im engeren Umfeld aber vor allem
auch im weiteren aber im Inneren immer
in Widerspruch und Misstrauen zu macht
gestanden haben und die könnten sich nun
ermutigt fühlen Gelegenheiten zu nutzen
um irgendwann dem großen führenden Arm
zu fallen vor allem dann wenn ihre
eigenen Interessen gefährdet sein
sollten ist denn der Westen darauf
ausreichend vorbereitet ich meine
gregorien ist ja nun wirklich alles
andere als ein Hoffnungsträger aber gibt
es irgendwelche Kontakte Richtung Moskau
jenseits von Putin aktuell
nun ja wir haben ja unverändert eine wie
ich finde sehr gute Botschaft in Moskau
und natürlich gibt es immer
gesprächsfäden und wir dürfen ja auch
nicht übersehen dass es grundsätzlich
viele gibt die präsidiabel wären in
Russland das ist auch ein Machtübergang
kann ja auch gut gehen und es kann
selbst in einem Ende des Krieges durch
jene führen die nicht begonnen haben
selbst brigorien hat gesagt das war kein
Grund für diesen Krieg also das ist
nicht auszuschließen natürlich ist
ebenfalls nicht auszuschließen das ist
vor allem wenn es zu wachsendem Unmut in
der Bevölkerung kommt es doch zu
massiven Widerspruch kommt und zur
inneren Verwerfung bis hin zu einer
Situation wie am Ende des Sowjetunion
das Teile des Landes beschließen sich
von Russland zu lösen zum Schluss noch
eine ganz generelle Frage vielleicht
Herr Botschafter das war ja wenn man
sich das immer Revue passieren lässt
gestern dann absurden zehn kaum zu
überbieten was wir da gesehen haben
irgendwie wirkt Putins macht Zirkel wie
Szenen vom Osmanischen Hof zumindest
mehr als ein modernes regierungszentrum
wie sehr blicken wir eigentlich wirklich
durch was da passiert wie sehr stochern
wir im Nebel
Winston Churchill hat einmal über den
Kreml gesagt dort kämpfen die Bulldoggen
unter dem Teppich und in die Knochen
rausfliegen wissen wir wer gewonnen hat
aber das waren andere Zeiten es gab ein
Zentralkomitee ein Politbüro das eine
gewisse Kontrolle beim Generalsekretärin
gegebenenfalls auch absetzte das gibt es
nicht mehr es gibt einen unumschränkten
Führer mit der geschilderten wankenden
Loyalität um ihn herum die er fürchten
muss aber einstweilen hat er die
Kontrolle über die Situation aber die
Situation wird gleichzeitig sehr viel
fragiler sagt Rüdiger von Fritsch lange
deutscher Botschafter in Moskau Herr
Botschafter vielen Dank für das Gespräch
heute Abend
sehr gerne
ja und das Leben in der russischen
Hauptstadt geht auf den ersten Blick
seinen Gang Wochenende Bummler mit
Coffee to go in der Innenstadt wenn man
nicht mehr sieht das sind die die sich
gestern aus dem Staub gemacht haben
Direktflüge waren plötzlich ausgebucht
Privatjets oben gleich dutzendweise ab
wir reden gleich über die Stimmung in
putinsreich erst Stimmen heute von
moskaustraße
denn es ist ohnehin ein Blutbad und wenn
es jetzt im Lande ein Durcheinander gäbe
das würde für niemanden gut ausgehen
natürlich ist der Frieden besser als der
Krieg es gibt ein Sprichwort ein
schlechter Frieden ist besser als ein
Krieg da Bär Schwester
in den letzten drei Jahren gefüttert
haben hat angefangen zu beißen ja das
war zu erwarten die Hauptfrage ist was
als nächstes passiert
von Lukaschenko überredet wurde dann
danke ich Lukaschenko sehr
zu Beginn des Krieges gegen die Ukraine
habe ich in dieser Sendung mit meiner
russischen Kollegin Marta fast
gesprochen die damals gerade aus
Russland geflohen war und jetzt wir
Georgien die Menschen in ihrer Heimat
informiert beim investigativ Magazin wie
Insider das Programm macht für Russland
heute ist sie wieder bei uns vor der
schönen guten Abend
guten Abend und jetzt hi hätten sie
jemals gedacht dass sie so einen Tag wie
gestern erleben würden so schnell
sind viele Dinge passiert in den letzten
eineinhalb Jahren ich habe nicht mit dem
Beginn des Krieges in der Ukraine
gerechnet ich war selbstverständlich
überrascht
eines der Themen mit denen ich mich
beruflich befasse ist die wagner-gruppe
ich habe mit einigen ehemaligen Wagner
seltenen gesprochen auch sie sind aus
Russland geflohen
[Musik]
mit einem habe ich gestern gesprochen er
erzählte mir er glaube nicht dass
pregorian Moskau erreiche oder dass es
eine Rebellion oder Revolution geben
werde
Rebellen Revolution
er hatte Recht aber das zweite was er
mir sagte war dass er nicht glaube dass
pregorian am Leben bleiben werde
sie haben nicht nur mit ex-wagner
Söldner geredet sondern natürlich auch
mit vielen Russinnen und Russen die er
hier Publikum sind jetzt haben wir
gestern ein paar Leute gesehen die
Wagner bejubelten tatsächlich wir haben
viele gesehen die mit campingstühlchen
an den Autobahn saßen und sich die
Spektakel muss man ja bei einer sagen
angesehen haben was wir nicht gesehen
haben sind sowas die Massenkundgebungen
für Putin wie würden Sie denn die
Reaktion ihrer Landsleute beschreiben
gestern
haha
das stimmt niemand ist auf die Straße
gegangen um den geliebten Präsidenten zu
beschützen ich scherze brigosin ist
nicht besonders bekannt in Russland sie
werden ihn in den Propaganda
Fernsehsender nicht sehen
[Musik]
vielleicht jetzt wo er nach Belarus
gehen wird keiner weiß genau was
passieren wird weil niemand von ihm in
den letzten 24 Stunden gehört hat denke
ich werden die Russen ihn komplett
vergessen
[Musik]
und wie verändert sich der der Blick der
Russinnen und Russen auf Putin der ja
immer unantastbar wirken wollte ist
dieser Mythos jetzt endgültig weg für
immer
also
ich glaube nicht dass die Situation rund
um die wagnergruppe einen Einfluss auf
die Meinung der Menschen in Russland
haben wird dass sie morgen oder
übermorgen Aufwachen werden mit dem
Gedanken oh putin ist nicht dieser tolle
Typ
en
also die Menschen sind bereits
desillusioniert haben das Interesse
quasi verloren an der Politik oder oder
was meinen Sie genau
ich glaube die Menschen sind in erster
Linie sehr müde besser gesagt ist das
der zweite Grund vor allem sind sie
verängstigt sie haben total Angst sie
haben Angst davor über den Krieg in der
U-Bahn zu sprechen ich kenne einige
Beispiele bei den Menschen nicht mal am
Telefon über das sprechen was passiert
weil sie denken dass jemand im Kreml
mithört thinking
Journalisten Kollegin mach was man noch
war russische Kolleginnen die jetzt aus
dem Ausland für ihr Heimatland sendet
was man aber herzlichen Dank für diese
Einblicke
und das Gespräch im Haus Termin Gründen
am Abend aufgezeichnet und damit nach
Deutschland der neue Landrat des Kreises
Sonneberg in Thüringen heißt Robert
Sesselmann warum sollte das auch die
interessieren die nicht im Kreis
Sonneberg leben weil es der bundesweit
erste Landrat ist den die AFD stellt
eine Partei die in Thüringen vom
Verfassungsschutz als erwiesen
rechtsextrem eingestuft und beobachtet
wird wie viel ist an dieser Wahl lokale
Politik in einer vergleichsweise
wirtschaftsstarken Region und wie viel
nationaler Trend Melanie Haack und
Daniela Sonntag sind in Sonneberg
Party mit Parteivorstand Jubel heute bei
der AFD und ihrem neuen Sonneberger
Landrat Robert Sesselmann die Partei
gewinnt ihren ersten kommunalen Amts
der Landkreis Sonneberg schreibt
Geschichte die AFD ist nunmehr als
Volkspartei hier im Kommunalbereich in
Thüringen und auch in der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland angekommen
aufzubauen die Grünen einzustreichen was
machen die Bürger gerade hier in
Thüringen in Sachsen in Ostdeutschland
im Mitteldeutschland die stellen einen
Ausreiseantrag zu AFD und das ist hier
heute
Jürgen Köpper von der CDU hatte bis
zuletzt alles mobilisiert doch ohne
Erfolg obwohl die Wahlbeteiligung mit
knapp 60% tatsächlich nach oben ging es
ist eine reine parteienwahl geworden und
was uns auf die Füße gefallen ist es
wirklich die unsägliche Politik der
Bundesregierung der kleinste Thüringer
Landkreis wirtschaftlich steht da gut da
die Arbeitslosenquote niedrig aber auch
die Löhne Corona Inflation
heizungsdebatte die Menschen sorgen sich
um den bescheidenen Wohlstand den sie
seit der Wände aufgebaut haben die AFD
kanalisiert eine lange angestaute Wut
und ziehen Sie abheizung Klimas ich bin
80 Jahre werde ich
alles ist hoch und da kann man ja nichts
mehr bezahlen man kann sie ja nichts
mehr leisten diese haben eine vorn
festkriegen
in Deutschland
doch in ihre eigenen Blase die wissen
nicht was das normale Volk anbelangt
wissen überhaupt nicht meckern im Ort
Steinach fragt sich auch bürgermeister
Ulrich kurz warum das hier mittlerweile
so üblich ist dass afd-ergebnis heute
hier
59,2%, die anderen Parteien gar nicht
mehr verankert also in Stein noch selbst
gibt es eigentlich keine großartigen
Aktivitäten von Ortsgruppen der Parteien
mehr wir haben so eine parteiunabhängige
Wählergruppe die aus der hervorgegangen
bin als Bürgermeister die aber auch in
ihren Aktivitäten die anfänglich gut
waren steigt nachgelassen hat war eben
die Akteure
älter geworden sind für Robert
Sesselmann und die AFD heißt es jetzt
aber auch Realpolitik machen auf den
Wahlplakaten waren noch bundesthemen
jetzt muss er im Landkreis die
Erwartungen der Wähler erfüllen
wenn man die letzten Umfragen als Basis
nimmt dann könnte die AFD in den drei
Bundesländern in denen nächstes Jahr
gewählt wird alle im Osten Deutschlands
stärkste politische Kraft werden nicht
aus eigener Kraft inhaltlich und
personell sei die Partei völlig blank
sagt der Ex afd-chef Jörg Meuthen die
guten Leute sein alle weg damit meint er
wohl auch sich für all die anderen
Parteien stellt sich auf jeden Fall die
Frage was heißt das jetzt für Sie dazu
mehr von Christian hübscher
zehn Jahre nach ihrer Gründung sechs
Jahre nach Einzug in den Bundestag
schafft die AFD den Präzedenzfall zum
ersten Mal erobert sie ein kommunales
Spitzenamt und Thüringens
Ministerpräsident scheint nicht mal
überrascht
es ist erstmal eine demokratische Wahl
und die Wählerinnen und Wähler in
Sonneberg haben eine Entscheidung
getroffen am Ende werden wir damit
umgehen müssen dass ein Kandidat gewählt
worden ist der hat das Vertrauen jetzt
in der Region bekommen der Thüringer AFD
landesschef höcke der selbst als
Rechtsextremist vom Verfassungsschutz
beobachtet wird hatte das Ziel
persönlich ausgerufen mit ganz viel Lust
an der Provokation
bestellt euch vor die AFD gewinnt ihren
ersten Landrat was wäre das für eine
Schlagzeile die Bundesrepublik
Deutschland würde Beben und das muss
doch unser Ziel sein das Prinzip alle
gegen die AFD ist in Sonneberg heute
erstmals geschaltet und das könnte sich
jederzeit wiederholen denn Stichwahlen
mit afd-beteiligung gibt es im Osten
immer öfter so zuletzt auch in Schwerin
in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern hier kann der
SPD-Mann in letzter Minute
Oberbürgermeister bleiben nur weil auch
hier sich alle für ihn zusammen taten
in Sachsen-Anhalt gibt es schon
kommenden Sonntag die nächste Stichwahl
wer wird Bürgermeister in Raguhn Jeßnitz
Hannes Loth von der AFD holte im ersten
Wahlgang 40 Prozent die CDU nur 5,8
jetzt trommelt sie gegen ihn ich
persönlich würde nie zur Wahl von jemand
anders aufrufen wenn ich selbst
unterlegen bin und wenn ich verloren
habe dann habe ich halt verloren niemand
bricht sich da und Zacken aus der Krone
wenn auch mal die SPD sagt unterstützt
hier die CDU oder die CDU sagt
unterstützt sie die SPD es geht um
Zusammenarbeit Demokraten gegen welche
die die Demokratie gefährden wollen laut
Umfragen findet eine Mehrheit solche
Zusammenschlüsse gegen die AFD richtig
35% finden Sie falsch im Osten sind noch
etwas mehr dagegen
und den Thüringen wo die AFD aktuell in
Umfragen mit 30% stärkste Kraft ist und
wo im kommenden Jahr eine Landtagswahl
ist hier hat so mancher ein stört Gefühl
wie kommt das bei den Wählern an wenn
alle anderen
inhaltlichen Programmatiken zurücknehmen
nur um die Partei AFD zu verhindern ich
glaube auf Dauer ist das ein schwieriger
Prozess der nicht aufgehen wird
Thüringen dürfte wieder mal als
Seismograph wirken was heute hier
passiert kann morgen woanders sein
den Blick auf die weitere
Nachrichtenwelt den hast du jetzt Hannah
ja da blicken wir zunächst auf die
Parlamentswahl
in given näher Demokratia laut
Hochrechnungen klar stärkste Kraft
geworden ist demnach erreicht die Partei
des bisherigen Ministerpräsidenten
mitzutakis 40,5 Prozent und kann die
künftige Regierung alleine bilden neues
Wahlgesetz begünstigt den Sieger nämlich
mit Bonus sitzen zweitstärkste Kraft ist
die Linke Siri sah von Ex-Regierungschef
cipras mit
17,8%. es war die zweite Parlamentswahl
in Griechenland innen fünf Wochen beim
letzten Mal hatte die näher Demokratie
gesiegt die Bildung einer Koalition war
aber gescheit hat
in Bremen haben sich SPD Grüne und Linke
auf eine Fortsetzung ihrer Koalition
geeinigt die Verhandlungen seien
erfolgreich beendet worden morgen soll
der Koalitionsvertrag vorgestellt werden
noch müssen allerdings die Landespartei
Tage zustimmen bei der Bürgerschaftswahl
vor sechs Wochen waren die SPD und
Bürgermeister bovenschulte mit
29,8% stärkste Kraft geworden
Sozialverbände und die Linke haben eine
Anhebung des gesetzlichen Mindestlohns
auf 14 Euro ab 2024 gefordert kurz bevor
die zuständige Kommission morgen ihren
Vorschlag dazu vorlegen will aktuell
liegt der Mindestlohn bei 12 Euro pro
Stunde
Sozialverbände und Linke verweisen unter
anderem auf die hohe Inflation aber auch
auf drohende Altersarmut für
Zurückhaltung plädierte dagegen
ifo-präsident Fust gegenüber der Funke
Mediengruppe die Mindestlöhne sollten
den allgemeinen Tariflöhnen Folgen
sofort
in Mekka hat der hat begonnen die
jährliche große Pilgerreise der Muslime
und das erstmals seit der
corona-pandemie wieder ohne
teilnahmebeschränkungen und Auflagen
10.000 der Gläubige umkreisten die Kaaba
im Innenhof der großen Moschee dass wir
für förmige Gebäude ist das zentrale
Heiligtum das Islam dieses Jahr wird mit
mehr als zweieinhalb Millionen Pilgern
aus 160 Ländern gerechnet der hat gehört
zu den fünf Säulen des Islam
all jene die sich professionell mit
unseren Meeren befassen sind aktuell
überrascht und beunruhigt zugleich seit
Mitte März ist das Oberflächenwasser der
Ozeane so warm wie noch nie selbst im
Nordatlantik hat es das seit Beginn der
Satellitenmessungen vor 40 Jahren nicht
gegeben besonders auffällig es ist nicht
eine kleine Abweichung nach oben sondern
eine enorme sowohl was die Temperatur
angeht als auch das betroffene Gebiet
was passiert dort gerade christina
kayatz ist der Frage nachgegangen die
Antwort die bereits feststeht es hat
Konsequenzen für Fische Meerestiere und
für uns Menschen
es sind beunruhigende Daten die
Messstationen derzeit aufzeichnen das
Wasser des Atlantiks ist ungewöhnlich
warm 23 Grad Celsius im Schnitt meldet
die us-klima-behörde Seiten
Forscher weltweit sind alarmiert
wir machen uns natürlich grundsätzlich
über die Erwärmung sorgen aber jetzt
diese besonders warmen Situationen im
superladen Nordatlantik und im
tropischen Atlantik führen dazu dass das
marine Ökosystem extrem unter Stress
gesetzt ist es ist im Moment sogar so
dass wir dort Temperaturen haben die
eigentlich in den letzten 100 Jahren da
gar nicht vorgekommen sind vielleicht
noch länger und so kann man gar nicht
wissen wie die Arten damit umgehen
die Erwärmung des Atlantiks ist Folge
des Klimawandels hinzukommen natürliche
Phänomene auf die der Mensch keinen
Einfluss hat darunter die sogenannte
nordatlantische Oszillation
ein Zusammenspiel zwischen dem Azoren
hoch und dem Island tief wenn sich das
Autoren hoch verstärkt fällt im Island
tief der Druck ab kräftige Westwinde in
den mittleren Breiten und starke
Passatwinde in den Tropen kühlen den
Ozean
[Musik]
wenn sich Island tief und Azoren hoch
abschwächen sind schwache West und
Passatwinde die Folge das Wasser des
Atlantiks wird dann weniger gekühlt
es sind also verschiedene Ereignisse die
sich überlagern mit dramatischen Folgen
die globale Erwärmung im Ozean sieht man
jetzt im Moment gerade sehr gut an der
Meeresoberfläche aber grundsätzlich
erwärmt sich das Meer und dadurch gibt
es eine Ausdehnung um mehr und einem
Anstieg des Meeresspiegels wir erwarten
mindestens noch einen Meter mehr als wir
bis jetzt schon haben
schon jetzt bereiten sich große
Hafenstädte wie etwa Rotterdam mit
gewaltigen sperrwerken auf immer höhere
Wellen vor doch auch Menschen weit weg
von den Küsten werden die Veränderungen
im Ozean spüren generell ist es so dass
wärmere Ozean natürlich zu mehr
Verdunstung führen das heißt es gibt
mehr Niederschlag wo der runterkommt
kann man nicht unbedingt sagen Kollegen
der ETH Zürich haben gezeigt dass von
der zusätzlichen Verdunstung durch die
globale Erwärmung das meiste in Form von
extrem Regenereignissen leider
runterkommt und damit nicht die auch
vorhandenen Dürre Probleme verringert
mehr als 70% der Erde sind von mehreren
bedeckt wenn sie sich verändern kann
unser Leben nicht mehr so sein wie
bisher
immer mehr immer stärker das droht uns
in Europa ein sehr heißer Sommer und er
hat ja bereits begonnen
so der Sport Sonntag jetzt im Überblick
mit Jana
20 Fußballer gehen vor dem em aus im
georgischen Batumi verlor das Team mit 1
zu 2 gegen Tschechien um das vorzeitige
Ausscheiden in der Gruppenphase doch
noch abzuwenden muss am Mittwoch ein
Sieg gegen em mit Favorit England her
und außerdem müssen die Israelis im
parallel spielen Tschechien schlagen
beim Triathlon Klassiker im
mittelfränkischen rot haben Anne Hauck
und Patrick lange jeweils den zweiten
Platz belegt und die beiden Sieger
schafften spektakuläre weltbestzeiten
bei den Frauen benötigte die Schweizerin
Daniela rief für die 3,8 km Schwimmen
180 km Rad und den Marathon 8 Stunden 8
Minuten und 21 Sekunden und bei den
Männern war der Dänemark in 7 Stunden 24
Minuten und 40 Sekunden so schnell wie
niemand je zuvor
[Applaus]
nach neuen Tagen mit spannenden
Wettkämpfen vor vollen Rängen sind heute
die Special Olympics zu Ende gegangen
die Spiele für Menschen mit geistiger
Beeinträchtigung und die Macher und
Athleten ziehen eine durchweg positive
Bilanz
die Special Olympics enden wie sie in
den vergangenen neun Tagen nicht nur
Berlin in ihren Bann gezogen haben als
friedlich fröhliches Sportfestes
Miteinanders und ansteckender
Lebensfreude wie von
beachvolleyballspieler Matthias Aigner
es war bombardastisch bei den
Weltspielen geistig beeinträchtigter
Menschen Rücken endlich jener
Athletinnen und Athleten in den Fokus
die zu oft ins stille Kämmerlein
abgeschoben werden
Mauern sind eingerissen worden wer
wüsste das besser als Berlin aber es
bleiben unsichtbare Hindernisse diese
Mauern aus Angst Diskriminierung und
Ausgrenzung müssen wir weiter einreisen
Zauberwort Inklusion in Perfektion
vorgelebt von knapp 20.000 freiwilligen
Gewinner alle überall
wie auch bei den kostenlosen
gesundheitshilfen von Kopf bis Fuß für
die 7000 Sportlerinnen und Sportler ihre
Glücksgefühle und den Lebensmut geben
sie allen Menschen mit auf den Weg für
die Zeit nach diesen bemerkenswerten
Special Olympics von Berlin
[Applaus]
wie immer an dieser Stelle am Sonntag
gucken wir jetzt auf die Woche vor uns
und was dann wichtig wird hier ist der
heute journal Ausblick von Kamera und
safariieren
[Musik]
wie erholen sich die Fischbestände in
der oder nach der öko-katastrophe im
letzten Jahr darüber berichten Forscher
des leibniz-instituts für
Gewässerökologie am Montag als Ursache
gilt die übermäßige Einleitung von
salzhaltigem Abwasser Nährboden für die
gefährliche Gold Alge zuletzt wurden
wieder tote Fische in neben Kanälen der
oder entdeckt
ab Dienstag werden die ersten Boote der
segelregatter Ocean Race im Zielhafen
von Genua erwartet Ambitionen auf den
letzten Etappen Sieg hat auch der
deutsche Boris Hermann mit seinem Team
Alicia zuletzt sorgten Angriffe von
Orcas auf die Boote für Aufsehen
finanzielle und militärische
Unterstützung für die Ukraine vor allem
darum geht es ab Donnerstag beim Treffen
der EU-Staat und Regierungschefs in
Brüssel seit Beginn des Krieges hat die
EU die Ukraine mit rund 72 Milliarden
Euro unterstützt
Emmanuel macron wird am Sonntag von
Bundespräsident Steinmeier empfangen es
ist der erste Staatsbesuch eines
französischen Präsidenten seit 23 Jahren
anlass ist der elisee-vertrag der vor 60
Jahren die deutsch-französische
Freundschaft besiedelte
fehlen noch die warmen wechselhaften
Wetteraussichten morgen im Norden
Durchzug von Schauern und teils
kräftigen Gewittern im Süden viel Sonne
und nur einzelne Gewitter 23 Grad an der
Nordsee bis 33 Grad im Südosten in den
nächsten Tagen im Norden leicht
wechselhaft im Süden oft sonnig bei
Höchstwerten zwischen 19 und 29 Grad
so damit packen wir hier zusammen sagen
danke für Ihr großes Interesse Morgen
begrüßen Sie hier Marietta Slomka und
Heinz Wolf und die nächsten Nachrichten
gibt's hier gegen 0.30 heute Express mit
Christopher Wehrmann machen sie es gut
Ihnen einen angenehmen Abend
[Musik]